[Music]
the best way to view the proposed
district plan is online via the e-plan
at
waimakariri.govt dot nz forward slash
e-plan
the e-plan works best in google chrome
it may also work in other browsers
however microsoft explorer is not
supported
the quickest way to find out which parts
of the district plan relate to you is to
search for your property type your
address into the search bar and click
enter
your property will appear on our
district map you can zoom in and out of
the map and move around to see other
properties in the various zones
you can toggle the visibility of the
different layers on and off by clicking
the boxes on the menu on the right hand
side of the screen the legend identifies
the different zones
the left hand side bar displays
information that's relevant to your
property
select property specific proposed plan
chapters to see which chapters directly
affect your property
this will only list the parts of the
plan that are relevant to you
if you want to read the entire proposed
district plan click the menu button on
the top left and select read the
district plan
the plan is split into three parts
an introduction
district-wide matters
and area specific matters
you can navigate around the various
chapters and read all the different
provisions using the menu on the left
all the underlying words can be clicked
and a helpful definition or explanation
will pop up
thanks for taking an interest in the
proposed district plan watch our next
video to learn how to give feedback
using the eggplan
if you're having any trouble a
step-by-step guide is available on our
website at waimakari dot govt dot nz
forward slash let's talk
you